c'est un minervois vins du languedoc et
ce petit nectar vient d'être classé
meilleur vin du monde par un jury
américain
plus qu'un prix c'est une consécration
pour le domus maximus d'autant que la
région a longtemps été décrié par les
palais les plus fins hélène vergne
pascal pons en croire les experts
internationaux ce vin est un bijou le
meilleur du monde issu tout droit du
languedoc et s'il a la surprise vient
des réputations qu'il faut abattre
je dirais jusque là le bordelais
l'emporter ou veb la bourgogne tout à
fait à la hauteur
une surprise mais pas une révélation
cela fait vingt ans que le vignoble du
languedoc roussillon produit des vins de
qualité au domaine mas sanier l'exigence
s'applique depuis toujours à cette vigne
mais l'acheteur n'était pas au rendez
vous alors ce trophée c'est un plus
incontestable
ça permet à tous ceux qui viennent pour
goûter le prix de goûter tous les vins
et et finalement on s'aperçoit que à 20
donne une renommée à une caf ont fait
pas du vent pensons aux prix ont fait qu
aux récompenses on fait du vin en
essayant de faire le mieux du mieux
qu'on peut et en régulièrement on essaie
de d'innover ou d'expérimenter des
nouvelles
façon de faire pourtant aucune recette
miracle pas l'ombre d'un ordinateur un
savoir faire artisanal aujourd'hui guidé
par un oenologue le travail d'équipé
permanents notamment lors de
l'assemblage la vigne produit les
raisins des raisins différent chaque
année en fonction des conditions du
millésime
on s'adapte le plus possible pendant la
vinification l' équilibre qui va exister
entre ces différentes puces c'est à nous
de le trouver
la concurrence la crise viticole qui
perdure le domaine mas sanier n'est pas
sorti d'affaires mais aujourd'hui les
commandes se succèdent son prestige tout
neuf lui permet de sortir de l'ombre